yeah welcome to this video another blitz
game five minute on a sec against grand
master from Hungary and I just need to
check quickly yeah this is alton med VG
the pretty good Grand Master all right
so I play this funny in knight c6 move
and let's see how we transpose into
something like the two nights the black
knights tango with g6 now and g 6 a-3
was played to prevent bishop before this
is one of the main moves in this
position and d6 now leads to some weird
Kings Indian cannot set up with g6 and
white now usually goes efore g3 or defy
the Sun is uncommon and all right so
should I go 95 now yeah I'm probably
retreating doesn't look so inviting uh
huh interesting
yeah it certainly makes them make sense
this kind of setup ok I want to make
sure that that does a pawn on d5 done my
ideas to go on now 98 to the six okay
yeah not c4 was some a possible threat
yeah what about move like f5s is
completely ridiculous it's not be five a
threat some interesting questions yeah
probably i should damn just play this
first to prevent 95 in any case yeah
okay he wants to play am probably night
to see 5 mm not sure might see 5 really
amounts to much foreplay let's say this
listener and detect this I mean 95 for
some could even play be 60 so just back
this may be very weakening but I'd like
to get some kind of active play here if
that is to play a form if 5e form and
then should be for coming or what yeah I
need to cover c7 all right not much that
I can do about that and potentially is
so eyeing this is six square but I can
prevent it at least night before for a
moment not sure I don't think I'm so
well so bad in this position c7 is a
weakness but it's so bad ready I spend a
bit turn on too much time but a position
as some may be okay before now maybe I
should have Connie for myself ok let's
let's do this
yeah only five the bishop potentially
covers c7 can move the night for example
and then cover it and it prevents Bishop
f4 I'm not prevent but dumb hmm really
92 m he wants to go to e6 I see I see
yeah this is may be debatable but what
can you do this was my idea I'm not sure
if it's a good idea but at least I'm how
do i get get this this pieces exchanged
maybe I need to do this pairing c7 I
have only got 40 seconds
I've got it protected for now in time
this was the idea h5 edge for now I
don't see him anyway to make any
progress here I'm warning ya last last
kind of try maybe and don't have
anything really he hasn't been too much
time on nothing particularly great ok
and I don't think that the position was
bad at all I was probably just better
done with no time on the clock it's more
than difficult yeah I could also resign
seven seconds and so yeah come on let's
uh let's resign um I think actually that
this should be I should be excellent for
black
yeah computer gives gives a clear
advantage no surprise I die it's tricky
to play because I ok I need to deliver
on the on the on the King side and he
simply place this stuff against the
seven which is very easy to do the a
computer wants to play a four and III
interesting is this may be may be bad
but ok me to play move I thought I could
somehow maybe exchange with Bishop h3
but it's difficult to accomplish
especially se Scott is this age 3 move
next next turn ok this Bishop e8 was
probably just nonsense I was thinking
maybe getting this one to f7 and play
against d5 but um ya des mentioned the
computer wants to play a form so can
maybe have a look at this I'm curious a
form Queen here Bishop to f5 yeah yeah
this looks good I'm threatening III and
white the white is nothing just just bad
and after this it one who wants to play
III yeah I mean okay i get a pawn to e
to probably Bishop g4 any two and this
is just a pawn weakness it's got the
kicking problem and um the bishops are
not doing so much yeah yeah well f3 was
just bad very complicated complicated
position but an interesting game I was
just slow alright thanks for watching